[موسيقى]
بعدين فتت بالتعبيريه التجريبيه من 2006
لهلا عم بشتغل على التجريد اللوني وتجديد
الغنائي والتجديد الهندسي
الرؤيه الاسلاميه والوهم البصري او الخداع
البصري كيف ممكن نحن ندخله مع التجريب
فبديت دور باللون ابحث باللون شوف شو ممكن
يوصل اللون للمتلقي وشو ممكن يكون
العلاقات الهندسيه والارقام الها دور هذا
البحث اللي صلي عليه هذا هلا تقريبا 12
سنه او 11 سنه
[موسيقى]
مرحله تعبيريه كانت تعتمد على الانفعال
المباشر لان اليوم انا عم بشتغل على عمل
معتمد على
الحسابات الجبريه على الطرق الهندسيه على
حسابات الالوان كميه التناغم كميه التناقض
بالعمل اللوني
القيمه الاكبر بتكون هي اللحظات اللي
قضيتها انا معها للوحه يعني مجموعه تراكم
الكلي للعمل الفني وكيف انا عكسته وكيف
كانت حياتي اثناءه هاي هي القيمه الفعليه
عندي للعمل
[موسيقى]
اخترت اللون مدخل لزيد شويه سعاده شويه
فرح شويه طاقه ايجابيه لو كل انسان لما
يدرك انه جواته هذا الفنان يواصل مشواره
لحتى يعطي اكتر واكتر واكثر واكثر
الانسانيه بحاجه لجمال
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات